[Musique]
on observe depuis le début de la
pandémie mais une étude est venu le
confirmer
les théories du complot gagne du terrain
au canada et l'adhésion aux
conspirations seraient liés à des
facteurs de stress psychosociaux près
d'un canadien sur dix succomberait aux
théories du complot entourant la
pandémie de kobe 19 selon tout le moins
les résultats préliminaires d'une
recherche menée par une équipe de
l'université de sherbrooke auprès de 600
citoyens
allons-y avec d'autres données tirées de
ce coup de sonde près de deux canadiens
sur deux croit que le quoran à virus
n'est pas naturelle près de 40% estiment
que le gouvernement leur cache des
informations importantes entourant le
corps anna virus et cette étude
préliminaire mais aussi en relief une
différence assez marquée entre le québec
et le reste du pays sur certains aspects
faut être très très prudent dans les
comparaisons près de 50 % des québécois
affirment faire confiance à leur
gouvernement contre seulement 26 8 % des
canadiens 18,6 pour cent des québécois
pensent que le koala virus a été créé en
laboratoire par rapport à 32,5 des
canadiens et si vous pensez que
l'adhésion aux théories du complot est
plus grande chez les personnes plus
âgées bien détrompez vous le sondage
indique plutôt le contraire pour chacun
d énoncer que je viens de vous présenter
maintenant ce qui peut être a priori
inquiétant c'est que le sondage montre
bien que l'adhésion théories
complotistes est associée à une plus
grande méfiance envers les gouvernements
et donc un moins bon respect des
consignes des autorités sanitaires
ce qui fait en sorte qu'on peut affirmer
que les forces nouvelles ont un effet
négatif sur la santé publique alors
comment expliquer les données de ce
sondage
selon marie-eve carignan co chercheuse
et professeur au département de
communication de l'université de
sherbrooke
il semble y avoir relié entre ceux qui
adhèrent aux fausses nouvelles et aux
complots en tous genres et des facteurs
de stress psychosociaux ces personnes
seraient même davantage
anxieuse ou davantage exposés à des
risques de trouble de stress post
traumatique
l'équipe de marie-eve carignan compte
réaliser d'ici quelques semaines un
deuxième sondage au canada et dans six
autres pays
on verra alors si on se compare on se
console ou non l'article de défier
dessus sur ce sondage vous attend sur
notre site web si vous
voulez en savoir un peu plus et
n'oubliez pas aussi d'un compte facebook
salut
[Musique]